can you explain the Blake Snyder beat
sheet sure so Blake came up with this
idea of you know sort of the 15 beats
that make up any story
um he put them on a beat sheet it's
become famous now for is a great tool
for people who are developing a story
idea I think or trying to learn about
story structure
um so the one I will say the one thing
that I think people who are introduced
to the beat sheet may be Overlook and
then have to learn later so this is a
shortcut is that some of the beats are
turning points and then some of the
beats are sections of the story so I'll
I'll go over them but it's useful to
note that because I think that's one of
the things that confuses people when
they're trying to learn about the 15
Beats
um okay so the opening image is sort of
the first image of your screenplay or of
your movie it sets the tone
um kind of establishes when and where we
are
um in the world right
um so the world of your story the next
beat that shows up on the beat sheet is
the theme stated and
um Blake wrote in save the cat I think
the theme stated shows up on page five
of your screenplay
um it's you know the theme is usually
the sort of like guiding principle or
the the big idea of the story what it's
really about kind of behind the plot and
behind the characters right
um and he liked to say that it was
stated somewhere in the story or you
know on page five of your screenplay it
was stated outright usually in a line of
dialogue by one of the characters
um the next beat on the um on the beat
sheet is the setup and that's one of
those beats to pay attention to because
the setup is actually a section of the
screenplay right so it's not just one
page or one scene it's a whole section
um I think he notes that it the setup is
like page one to page 12 or so
um and so that's introducing us to the
main character and with their Ordinary
World or their normal World sort of
where they are in their life right now
um before the story gets started right
and one of the things he wrote about in
save the cat was that um you can kind of
use the idea of at home at work and at
play to introduce your protagonist so
seeing them in these different sort of
aspects of their their normal World
gives us a sense of who they are the
next beat on the beat sheet is the
Catalyst and that is a beat that should
be
um more of a turning point like one
scene or One Moment In Your screenplay
um the catalyst is also something that
other people refer to as the inciting
incident it's really the event that
kicks the story into motion
um sometimes you can think of it as the
why now of the story it's this event
sort of you know throws your protagonist
world into disarray or forces them into
action by creating some sort of problem
or opportunity for them that they have
to take advantage of that they have to
deal with right and that's how it starts
the story into motion the next beat is
the debate section and again it's a it's
a section of the screenplay so this
isn't just one scene
um I keep emphasizing that because I've
seen writers get confused and when
they're trying to outline their stories
they get to like the debate section and
they they put in one scene and then when
they go to write the screenplay they
don't have enough story to sort of fill
out the pages right
um so the debate section is where is
that section in between the Catalyst or
the inciting incident sort of kicking
the story into motion and your
protagonist deciding what to do about it
so there's that debate section in
between there
where we really um
try to sort of close all of the obvious
doors for your protagonist and funnel
them toward this main thing that they're
going to do over the course of the story
right uh I also like to look at the
debate section as getting the audience
on board so you kind of tell us what's
at stake for the protagonist why they
have to do this thing because usually
the thing that they're going to do in
act two is this big audacious crazy
scary dangerous thing right so the
debate section use that to get the
audience on board and show us why do
they need to do this thing why is it so
important what happens if they don't do
it help us understand what the potential
consequences are so that we have that
tension of like wanting them to do it
but being a little bit worried about
them right before they go into act two
uh so the next beat is the break into
act two so at the end of the debate
section after you've gone through all of
that gotten the audience on board shown
us why the character has to do this
thing the break and act 2 is the turn in
your plot where you send the protagonist
into Act 2 onto that main Adventure
um pursuing that story goal engaging in
the main conflict however you want to
look at it that's where that's what the
break into Act 2 does
um the next section is the
B story then the next beat is the is the
B story so
um Blake liked to say that you know sort
of after that main or that after that
major plot point of the break into act
two
um it was a good time to give your
protagonist and your audience a little
bit of a breather and then introduce a
subplot
um he talked about the B story being
sort of the relationship or the subplot
where your character could discuss
learning the theme
um so a lot of times it'll be you know
it might be a romance or it might be a
friendship or something but it's giving
your character an opportunity to talk
about what he's learning talk about what
he's going through and what he's
learning from it
the next uh beat on the beat sheet is
fun and games and again this is a
section of the story so uh the fun and
games is actually on the beat sheet it's
all of the first half of act two right
so it's it's basically everything after
the break into two up until the midpoint
which we'll get to in a sec but so the
fun and games uh Blake wrote that it was
the is where we see the promise of the
premise so um whatever the concept is of
your story the thing that's hooky and
intriguing about you know this story
that's where we see it sort of come to
fruition is in the fun and game so
um I think his famous examples are Liar
Liar it's where we see Jim Carrey
getting used to not being able to tell a
lie uh or in Legally Blonde it's where
we see L getting acclimated to Harvard
Law and she's very much a fish out of
water
um so that's fun in game stuff you can
also think of it as trailer moments
right
um those those very entertaining and
very like sort of on concept moments or
scenes that you would probably cut into
a trailer to show somebody what's so
entertaining about your movie
um
the next beat is the midpoint so that's
you know the middle of your story
um the midpoint is a is a
more of a moment or a scene instead of a
section so again just making that
distinction but the midpoint can be a
few scenes in a row right it's not
really a section of your screenplay but
it can be a sequence because usually
it's a big set piece or like an action
sequence or something that is a little
bit bigger than other scenes right and
really the function of the midpoint is
to increase the opposition and or raise
the stakes of your story so basically
what it comes down to is the midpoint is
increasing the tension in your story to
sort of give it more momentum to get
through the second half right so
sometimes it turns the story in an
entirely New Direction but doesn't
always have to
um in any case what it does is it it
increases sort of that that tension
feeling so that it's sort of like you
know winding up a toy and letting it go
so it gives us that extra momentum and
energy to get through the second half of
the story then after the midpoint the
next beat on the beat sheet is the bad
guys close in
so Blake liked to say that this is sort
of where
um things really start going wrong for
your protagonist right so you can have
both external and internal bad guys so
it can be plot stuff is going wrong the
literal bad guys can be closing in you
know getting closer gaining on your
protagonist but it can also be
um emotional stuff they're really
struggling with what they're doing they
feel like they can't succeed and maybe
they're having a crisis of Faith or of
confidence
um
and then you can also have conflict
within the protagonist team so that's
also causing things to fall apart right
and basically the bad guys close in
section is leading us sort of downhill
towards the next couple of Beats which
are the
um All Is Lost and Dark Night of the
Soul Beats and these are separate beats
on the beat sheet but I sort of like to
talk about them together because they
really are complementary and they work
together to kind of create that low
point at the end of act two
um so I I sort of like to think of them
as one is
um more external or plot focused and one
is more internal or character focused uh
the All Is Lost is
um usually the sort of what I think of
as the plot focused one right where it's
it looks like the character the
protagonist is not going to succeed it
you might think of it as he's you know
as far away from his goal as he'll ever
be or he feels like he's failing he
feels like there's no hope he doesn't
know how he's going to keep going on and
try to get that goal
um and then the Dark Knight of the soul
is sort of the emotional reaction to
that
um other things that can happen at the
All Is Lost can be like the death of a
mentor I think this is where uh Blake
wrote that there's like that whiff of
death right so it can be the loss or
death of a mentor or of a friend or of a
support system
um it can be a major setback like
um you know being exposed to the bad guy
so now they know who who they're up
against or it can be like losing an
advantage you know but you want it to be
pretty big because we're talking about
kind of the big turning points of the
story
um and then the darkener the soul is the
emotional reaction to that right so it's
now that this big setback has happened
or it looks like I'm not going to be
able to achieve my goal the protagonist
sort of sitting in that for a moment and
wondering what do I do from here
and a lot of times that's where they
have kind of a glimmer of
I finally understand the lesson of the
theme I finally understand what I should
be learning from this experience
um
they they're not always ready to embrace
that lesson at that point yet right but
they're starting to understand like oh
this is what all of this has been trying
to teach me
um and then after that the next beat is
the break into Act 3.
um so that's the major turning point
where we go from Act 2 to act three and
um basically it's the beginning of the
resolution section of the story right so
that turn you usually want it to feel
like it's sort of pushing us in a new
direction that is toward however the
story is going to resolve right so your
character your protagonist might have a
new plan so after that Dark Night of the
Soul moment they might have a moment of
inspiration where they're like oh okay
now I know what I what I need to do I
now I know how to defeat this bad guy
and so the break into three is where
they begin that that final push to
resolve that story right that main
conflict or
um you know however you want to think
about that that story so the next beat
on the beat sheet after the break into
act 3 is the finale and this is the
section that most people forget is a
section of the story instead of
um one scene right so your finale or the
way Blake wrote about the finale
um is that the finale was all of act
three so it's what you would call the
resolution right or he called it the
finale
um
so this is where we see that new plan
that your protagonist has play out or we
see them execute that that final push
toward trying to resolve the main
conflict
um so finale all of act three
um I think that is that is that beat 14
and then there's 15 is the final image
okay so the last beat on the beat sheet
is the final image so that's after the
finale has played out we've seen how the
main conflict has resolved we've seen if
the protagonist has you know achieved
his goal if they've succeeded or failed
how the out you know how the story
um ends basically like what is the final
outcome and then we have the very last
beat which is the final image which sort
of is that you know you might think of
it as like almost the aftermath of the
of the finale it's now that the story is
over give us one kind of final scene or
image or moment to kind of send the
audience out feeling how you want them
to feel
um knowing maybe what the character is
going to do next or
um you know if you need to sort of
recalibrate the the emotion at the end
of your story maybe the maybe the um the
end of the finale was a big action
sequence and you want to leave us
feeling like knowing that your
protagonist is okay and he won and he's
safe and he's you know rested and not
injured anymore or something like that
the final image can can do that
um Blake also liked to write that it was
uh the final image is like a bookend for
the opening image right so you know I
think
um some people look at it as you want
the the change or the contrast between
the opening image and the final image to
be big enough to sort of uh show that
there was a transformation in that in
that story right so we went from point A
to point Z and there's a big enough
contrast there that we can see this
story you know covered some ground and
had some consequence to it if that makes
sense